INSTRUCTOR: I want to
illustrate the important notion
of stiffness by running ode45,
the primary MATLAB ODE solver,
on our flame example.
The differential
equation is y prime is y
squared minus y
cubed, and I'm going
to choose a fairly--
an extremely small
initial condition, 10
to the minus sixth.
The final value of t
is 2 over y naught,
and I'm going to impose a
modest accuracy requirement, 10
to the minus fifth.
Now let's run ode45
with its default output.
Now, see it's taking-- it's
moving very slowly here.
It's taking lots of steps.
So I'm take- pressing
the stop button here.
It's working very hard.
Let's zoom in and see why it's
taking so many steps, very
densely packed steps here.
This is stiffness.
It's satisfying the accuracy
requirements we imposed.
All these steps are within
10 to the minus sixth of one,
but it's taken very
small steps to do it.
These steps are so small
that the graphics can't even
discern the step size.
This is stiffness.
It's an efficiency issue.
It's doing what we asked for.
It's meeting the
accuracy requirements,
but it's having to take
very small steps to do it.
Let's try another
ODE solver-- ode23.
Just change this to 23
and see what it does.
It's also taking very small
steps for the same reason.
If we zoom in on here, we'll
see the same kind of behavior.
But it's taking very
small steps in order
to achieve the desired accuracy.
Now let me introduce
a new solver, ode23s.
The s for stiffness.
This was designed to
solve stiff problems.
And boom, it goes
up, turns the corner,
and it takes just a few steps
to get to the final result.
There it turns the
corner very quickly.
We'll see how ode23s
works in a minute,
but first let's try
to define stiffness.
It's a qualitative
notion that doesn't
have a precise
mathematical definition.
It depends upon the
problem, but also
on the solver and the
accuracy requirements.
But it's an important notion.
We say that a problem is stiff
if the solution being sought
very slowly, but there are
nearby solutions that very
rapidly.
So the numerical method
must take small steps
to obtain satisfactory results.
Stiff methods for ordinary
differential equations
must be implicit.
They must involve formulas
that involve looking backward
from the forward timestep.
The prototype of these methods
is the backward Euler method,
or the implicit Euler method.
This formula, it involves--
defines y n plus 1,
but doesn't tell us
how to compute it.
We have to solve this
equation for y n plus 1.
And I'm not going to go into
detail about how we actually
do it.
It involves something
like a Newton method
that would-- requires
knowing the derivative,
or an approximation to
the derivative of f.
But this gives you
an idea of what you
can expect in stiff methods.
I like to make an
analogy with taking
a hike in one of
the slot canyons
we have here in the Southwest.
Explicit methods
like ode23 and 45
take steps on the
walls of the canyon
and go back and forth across
the sides of the canyon,
make very slow progress
down the canyon.
Whereas implicit
methods, like ode15s,
look ahead down the
canyon and look ahead
to where you want to go and make
rapid progress of the canyon.
The stiff solver, ode23s,
uses an implicit second-order
formula and an associated
third-order error estimator.
It evaluates the partial
derivatives of f with respect
to both t and f at each
step, so that's expensive.
It's efficient at
crude error tolerances,
like graphic accuracy.
And it has relatively
low overhead.
By way of comparison,
the stiff solver ode15s,
can be configured to use
either the variable order
numerical
differentiation formula,
NDF, or the related to backward
differentiation formula BDF.
Neither case it
saves several values
of the function
over previous steps.
The order varies automatically
between one and five,
it evaluates the partial
derivatives less frequently,
and did see efficient at
higher tolerances then 23s.